I
good afternoon we have a runner tops who
is going to talk about massively
parallel processing with procedural
Python he works for pivotal pivotal
pivotal and yeah thanks for the
introduction yeah we we have some links
up for this talk so there's an iPad
notebook that has all of the code
examples we will be looking at today and
it's also on NB viewer and i will post
my slides and speaker deck later on so
you can have a look at those are quickly
about pivotal so we were founded in 2013
out of parts of vmware emc and green
plum we have three core components which
is agile development platform as a
service and big data i am myself I work
for pivotal data labs I'm a data
scientist and we do agile data science
engagements we also have pivotal labs
which do agile application development
and we have at the core of our company
is cloud foundry which is a leading
open-source platform as a service and it
we aspire to be the Linux of the cloud
there and that that is showing some real
encouraging growth we also have a very
competitive Big Data sweet we have a
Hadoop distribution pivotal HD we have a
massively parallel processing database
we're actually the market leader there
it's called green plum and we have an
in-memory database called gemfire okay
so what do what does a typical customer
of us look like during a data science
engagement well usually there are very
large enterprises that work with
terabytes or petabytes of data but
they're not really making use of that
data to its fullest potential so
oftentimes have all legacy systems was
very slow response times after of the
queries and may take hours and
together to get any sort of insights on
these on these data sets and there is no
way to do agile data science or they'd
order stuck with all legacy bi systems
where they can only deal with data that
they can load into memory so what we do
is we transform these enterprises into
data driven enterprises but we also lead
support and contribute to many
open-source projects so some of the more
popular ones you will definitely
recognize use Redis we did we lead Redis
will lead spring we do RabbitMQ Grails
groovy Cloud Foundry as I've already
mentioned we do we contribute a lot to
do one library that is that the center
here it's called mad lib that is our in
database scalable machine learning
library and I will talk about about that
more later we also have a couple of more
smaller open source projects one of
particular interest to you guys would be
pi Madlib which is a python wrapper for
machine learning library Madlib will
also have a look at that later and
during a typical data science engagement
we work with green plum or how our
Hadoop distribution pivotal HD so you
may ask where where does Python come
into all of this we do a lot of
exploratory data analysis like the rest
of you and I pies notebook using pandas
metal metal art lib and all the other
great libraries out there but we've
already heard a lot about this what I
want to talk to about today is PL pious
and procedural Python which enables you
to run Python functions inside of your
database or inside of your sequel on
Hadoop engine and was that your you're
able to use great libraries like NLT k
and scikit-learn within your database
and that is a very powerful concept as i
will show so on to peel python itself
the the basic idea of pol python is to
reduce data movement to a minimum you
want to bring the code to the data and
not in the data to the code so what a
lot of people do they connect to a
database and then they load the data
into memory and if the data set is big
it was first of all it incurs a lot of
network traffic and secondly it might
not even fit into into main memory so
what we try to do is we push the code
onto the database or onto our SQL on
Hadoop engine wear it then what we then
do the machine learning right in the
database so I'm going to show you how to
do this so I'm a user-defined function
in an SQL database it's just essentially
a curry you can pass arguments to and
the syntax of these PL pipes and
functions they're essentially just as
normal Python functions we have in here
with a sequel wrapper so the sequel
wrapper up there we have to we have to
pass the types of the arguments and
sequel is a strongly typed language but
other than that it's exactly the same as
we would do in a normal Python function
definition down here it says we have to
we have to state the language of we're
using it says peel Python you you may
wonder what the use stands for it stands
for untrusted peel python is an
untrusted language or in databases at
the moment and that is because was
Python as you know you can call
arbitrary system commands and that is
obviously a little bit of a nightmare to
two system administrators but sadly that
is just the way it is at the moment the
function itself needs to include a
return or yield statement and let's have
a look at some live code that the
ipython notebook so I hope this this
works fine it's the font big enough for
the people in the back good good stuff
ok so um
so what I'm doing here I am loading the
sequel extension here which was written
by Catherine Devlin you can you can
download that it's it's completely free
and all I'm doing here is connecting to
a local instance of a green plum
database I have running on my machine
and then we can define a function here
so this is just our PI max function
we've seen before it just finds the
maximum of two integers here and you can
you can define this and then it does
what you expect here you call these
functions just you can call them in a
select statement so select pi max of two
or five and of course five is the bigger
number we can also change it here and it
will execute just fine and we get 11 as
expected so back to our presentation if
we so if we want to return a multiple
results we can do this by creating a
composite type and this is done was to
create type statement so in this case we
create a named named value it's just a
tuple of a name and a value and we do
this year in the create type and what we
can then do within our Python code we
can just return a tuple we can return a
dick tour list and then a database knows
how to put those into individual rows if
we actually want to return multiple rows
then we can use this set of notation up
here we we say create function make pair
returned set of name value and what it
does then it it fills multiple roles in
your database in addition to multiple
columns we can also use generators
statements within our p.o Python
functions and but what is really of most
interest to us data scientists is that
we can access packages such as numpy
side by side
learn and so on from within the database
so to do this you have to ensure that
the packages are installed on all of
your data base notes or Hadoop notes or
whatever it may be and once that is done
you can just use import for example your
import numpy it just as you always do so
let's have a look at some more code in
the ipython notebook so what we do what
I did here is I created a composite type
that we've just seen a name value and
what we can then do is we can create a
function name pair in this case it just
midst the tuple again and then we can
call this function and it works just as
expected here so what is different than
two ordinary a Python though is that a
sequel allows for multiple function
definitions was the same name just the
function signature has to be different
so in this case here we have we just
passed a name without the value and but
the function has the same name make pair
and what we do here is we import numpy
this time and create a value
programmatically but we can if we define
this function it just it runs just fine
it's done and we can use this function
here and sequel will know how to pick
the function by the number of arguments
you provide to it so if i change the
argument here i go and put horatio 11
and i execute this again it will it will
execute the function we have defined up
here the function where you pass a name
and a value to this function so what
we've done up to now was that we call
the function from what's in the Select
statement and yet as you may have
noticed what it returns is a is a tuple
and not multiple columns what we've
normally want to do in cville so the way
you can return multiple columns is that
you do not call the pl sequel function
from the Select statement but instead
from
from statement then your database knows
how to put the return values into
multiple columns and this is what
happens here all right and if we want to
return multiple rows and multiple
columns we have to use the set of
notation I mentioned earlier and what
happens then we can define this function
and what we do in in the loop here is we
loop over multiple name value two balls
and if we execute this it returns then
here multiple rows and multiple columns
so to understand the next section since
this talk is called massively parallel
data processing with Python I have to
quickly introduce what a massively
parallel architecture is in the first
place it can either be an MPP database
or it may be Hadoop so in the in the
case of green plum you can think of
green plum as multiple postgres service
working together they are coordinated by
a master node and there are a lot of
worker nodes that all work in parallel
but to the user it just looks like
ordinary Postgres database except a lot
of engineering effort has gone into it
to make it seamlessly execute the Kurian
korean parallel so the master node it
remembers where all the data is stored
and it sends the right parts of the
query to the right notes and the nodes
will send the data back to the master
and we have a much much more scalable
database and a green pump is actually a
fork of phosphorus so you get all the
postgres goodies such as post gears and
all the other great extensions in
Postgres so how does this relate to peel
pies and you may ask well what we've
done before is we just call the function
all of our day
now if it's stored in a cluster maybe a
Hadoop cluster or MPP database such as
green plum then we'll incur a lot of
data traffic because all of the nodes
they have to send the data into the
function on one particular node that
then does the computation and it's going
to be slow and horrible and big disaster
so how do we get around this well we
have to think about parallelization
within the database so what I've done
here is I've created some example data
it's just three series we have one one
variable that is just a categorical
variable here the letter a B or C and
then a series X and a series why and
both of these series they're there three
million observations long it's just some
some example data and now we define a
function NP mean that uses numpy to find
the mean of an array and like i've
mentioned we we have to define that we
have to define the function we have to
define the argument types and since SQL
a strongly typed but other than that
here we can just import numpy and we can
call NP mean of the value array and it
will return the mean so to do this to
pass an array into numpy we need to use
the postgres function array aggregate
what that simply does is it takes a
column of data and it transforms it into
an array and then pass it passages into
a function so once we do this and we
executed we get the mean of the of the y
column here and it's all good but the
problem is this doesn't execute in
parallel so though so this just execute
someone node and we we get a lot of
traffic and in a long run time in a
distributed system so how when it may we
paralyze it in this toy example here we
had these different names here so so all
the series where
in categories so what we can actually do
when we call this mean function we can
now group by the name column and what
the system then does it intelligently
paralyzes over over the data so this
there's no more data movement and
actually the query execute in parallel
and let's have a look at a more
interesting example so mmm so what we do
here is we define a function called Lin
Lin regression it's just linear
regression we pass an x-ray and a why
array into the into the function and
then inside of the function we import
stats from sci-fi and we just use the
linear regression functional and we can
define this function here and it just
just run fine yes and then we can
execute it again as we've already seen
but the problem again is this does not
run in parallel and it's not infinitely
scalable so how do we solve this the
same way as we've done with the mean we
group by name and then then it simply
estimates three models in parallel and
we get the model coefficient we get the
p-values and so on but the problem with
this approach is you may need a global
model so not all problems can be boiled
down to to some submodels we have a lot
of cases where that we can do that for
example if a customer gives us sales
data for all of Germany then we can fit
sup models for each state and it usually
works just fine but in a lot of cases
that we need a global model so how do we
do this first of all before we get to
the global models let's just recap some
of the benefits of using PL Python first
of all we can bring the code to the data
and not vice versa what would usually
have
and especially in corporate environments
databases is usually where the data
lives and when sequel when our when our
sequel falls short we can leverage our
Python experience to do basically
whatever we want to within the database
and we can we've actually done this in
real Clark projects we've applied the PI
data stack to petabytes of data which is
not easily done of course on a single
machine and what is often overlooked too
is that the results they're already
inside of the database so you don't
usually want these results in the
database so when you have an app the app
can create this model or these results
and you you have them ready for further
analysis and storage so you don't send
data out of the database process it and
then send the results back into the
database it all happens within the
database so what I've just mentioned
earlier was what if we want to fit a
global model and this is not easy easily
achieved with something like procedural
Python well we have Madlib for this I've
mentioned this at the beginning it it's
our open source open source scalable in
database machine learning library and
what it does it's a collection of
algorithms that are specifically
designed to leverage cluster
architecture to to fit global models in
parallel but using all of the memory of
the full cluster and matlab was
initiated in 2010 by some some
researchers at UC berkeley and at green
plum and the idea was to collect collect
a lot of in database algorithms these
people had been using all along so Matt
lip is actually quite amateur project
now we have a lot of algorithms both
unsupervised and supervised learning
we have k-means clustering we have
elastic net regression we have decision
trees we have random forests we have
flattened delay allocation we have
things like conditional random fields so
it's actually a lot of a lot of
algorithms in theirs and you can it's
completely free it's open source besides
on green plum and our SQL on Hadoop
engine Hawk it also runs within postgres
of course if you run it in Postgres you
do not get the parallelization but you
do get the benefit that you can fit
models that do not fit into memory and
you also get the benefit that your data
does not have to move out of the
database so how does madlib actually
work the the very low-level matrix
routines there are all C++ with
well-known libraries such as boost but
the driver functions it's actually all
Python code with some templated SQL so
if you download the project you you can
you can have a look at this and and it's
it's fairly understandable this is
another place where we use a lot of
Python now let's have a look at some
real real world examples of how we use
Python especially peel pie from during
our data science engagements so one of
my colleagues in San Francisco from our
healthcare vertical a leak row she is a
biomedical PhD and she she recently she
completed some pioneering work in in
database image processing using PL
Python so what we see up here on the
right this is actually a image of some
cancerous breast tissue and what she did
is she read these many many of these
images into a database in the following
format it's actually quite simple and
you just under on the very left most
column you just have the name
of the image then you store the row and
the column of a given pixel and the last
three last three columns there are the
intensity values of the red green and
blue spectrum so it's actually quite the
intuitive and simple way of storing
images in a structured format inside of
your database and in this way and we are
able to circumvent many of the
traditional challenges of image
processing so usually if you get a huge
image say from a satellite or also in
this case medical images they're often
so large it's difficult to process them
in memory and especially it gets
thousands in even millions of these
images putting them in a database and
processing them in parallel really does
make a lot of sense there's also other
use cases such as detecting malfunctions
for example in manufacturing so how does
this look like well there's there's
actually a lot of steps in counting and
detecting these cancerous tumor and dis
cancer cells in the breast tissue but
the first step of this is smoothing this
happens a lot of time in image
processing so what she's done here is
she's just defined a function here
called smooth and she uses the uniform
filter from Sify to to apply the
smoother to to the image and then up
there in the Select statement she just
calls this Python function to smooth the
image so this would be something that
would be really difficult to implement
in pure sequel and we can really
leverage our our Python experience here
to to get these things done it's
actually quite quite cool another
example is a social media analysis so
another colleague of mine in the u.s.
rivets on drama druna he has created a
very very nice pipeline for processing
the Twitter Decker house which is
actually ten percent of the
total twitter feed this is approximately
55 million tweets per day and with you
spring XD to ingest this data into HDFS
and then we use nightly cron jobs to
parse this data into into our sequel on
Hadoop engine Hawk but you can you can
use other frameworks too and we've used
PL Python to parse this raw JSON data
and loaded loaded into the database what
we've done then is to to to run some
machine learning algorithms and generate
some insight on this data we again we
use Madlib and we run a Latin deviously
a location on a given set of tweets and
then we are able to find a set of topics
for this tweet so so lda is an
unsupervised learning method that is
able out of a corpus of text to find
some common topics another method we use
is unsupervised sentiment analysis and
we've actually used appeal pison for
this again because it's an easily
parallelizable method and what we've
done is we assign a sentiment score too
every single tweet by looking at phrases
and seeing whether they are positive and
negative and then you can enter a curry
off your liking and see how the
sentiment for that query trends over
time and and we we build a very nice a
web front and with this in cooperation
with our application development team
pivotal labs sadly I was going to show
you a live demo of this but my VPN seems
to be down but I've loaded the page
earlier today so this is this is the
interface we can enter a search term
here by the way for this demo this is
all all tweets from 2013 it's it's not
our life system july 2030
in fact and we can enter search terms
such as Obamacare here this was a very
very hot topic in the US in 2013 I
cannot execute this now because I'm not
on the VPN but I've actually I've loaded
this page earlier so we can have a look
at the results the rendering is a bit
off now because the resolution changed
due to the projection here but you can
get a sense of what this does we can see
the number of tweets as they trend over
time and we also get to see here a
sentiment mapping we did in PL pipe and
I talked about earlier so this is all
for Obamacare again and we can see the
green line here is the number of
positive tweets we have the red line
this is the number of negative tweets
and the gray line is the number of
neutral tweets and you can hope hover
over this and you see the number of
tweets and so on and here on the right
we see the the top 20 negative tweets
during that time and we can see the the
sentiment mapping is actually quite
accurate here it says the latest victim
of Obamacare so this is surely quite
negative we get here another major
hurdle and fight against Obamacare so
this is working quite well we can also
click on the on the top 20 positive post
and this is all quite dynamic we get
here a heat map with with a number of
tweets by time of day and weekday so it
looks like that here on Thursday was a
good time to tweet about Obamacare him
and we also get some word clouds down
here we we have some topic clusters we
can look at and so on these these are
also quite interesting so this is this
is the result from the Latin usually a
location we ran earlier and yeah we can
hover over those and have a look at the
tweets here so this was quite a negative
cluster here it says blame it on
Obamacare and so on you your words and
weren't using that disposal incoming
so yeah we can have a sort of a
drill-down look on this and we can also
click on this and never well it doesn't
load know since I'm not connected life
to the VPN but well yeah okay so back to
the slides another cool demo we did
using PL Python was did a colleague of
mine in Houston and Lana he actually
held this talk at PI data loanin earlier
this year and he build the demo
predicting the duration of traffic
incidents in London he did this with
open data that is available from
transport of London it's the it's the
local traffic authority in London and he
pulled in that data using peeled Python
into the green plum database he also
pulled in data from Weather Underground
and then since the there was quite a lot
of data this data munging could not have
been memory so what we did here we did a
lot of deduplication feature creation
data munging within the database and
then we use scikit-learn to create a
model to predict the duration of any
given incident and we build a nice web
front-end for this and which is actually
hosted on Cloud Foundry our platform as
a service and actually our our pivotal
labs team is currently building a mobile
app out of that so so there will be
Android app available for for this at
some stage and this this is not this
demo is not affected by my VPN so it can
actually show this to you let's reload
this page it should work yes so here we
see a table of all the current traffic
incidents in London which is very few
usually there's like 30 30-something
traffic incidents in London and we can
hover over this and it will give us your
little comments also there's a burst
water main and this incident is already
been lasting for 33 hours and predicted
time remaining from our model is 14.1
hours we also get a nice map of all the
traffic incidents here we can we can
also zoom out we can click on these and
we can see the predicted time remaining
of of these traffic incidents so there's
also some analysis available here with
some nice these three charts we can see
the number of traffic incidents over
time here can hover over those and what
we also see here is the number of the
average number of incidents by week day
and time of day and the red line here
Sunday so as we saw just now there's
very few traffic incidents on sundays
usually and what was also quite visible
here is the two peaks here during rush
hour on weekdays and yeah this is also
some other distributions here and and we
can look at a few more stats to to
compare this we both these demos just
sort of to demonstrate our stack and do
some interesting data science projects
because a client projects we usually can
show this to to the public these results
and yeah feel free to get in touch I
hope you had a very nice PI data
conference and I'm going to tweet my
slides on speaker deck later so you can
get all these links and so I hope you
still have a good time in Berlin and I
think we have a time for a little bit of
a QA
thank you for the very interesting talk
and very interesting use cases as well
so we have time for questions yeah first
of all I think it's a very interesting
approach to bring new computational into
the database so my question is whenever
you do data processing in a distributed
database the efficiency of your
operations always heavily depend on how
you've petition the data that's correct
yes can you say a little bit about it
yeah so if you if you do a group by
operation like we did earlier here we
group by name so if we go back to the
ipython notebook here what we did for
example we executed this linear
aggression and it group by name what we
should do earlier if we if we create the
data is it's also to distribute the data
by name so so the for example the the
data from this a series we had up here
it's on the same on the same here we
generated this a series it's actually on
the same cluster node so there's no data
movement so you have to think a little
bit about this in advance so actually
I've done this year I forget to forgot
to mention it the data is actually
distributed by name here so so we did
the right thing and well yeah you have
to you have to think about this in
advance besides distributing the data
there's also you can also partition the
data so this is for example if you have
time series data this is usually a good
idea for example if you if you have if
there was dates here now too and we
would want to fit submodels for say
every year or something like this we
could partition by year and then the
database would align all the data on
disk for a given year so that so the
diskette does not need to keep rereading
that data
then it runs a lot faster so yeah you
you do have to put a little bit of
thought into that thanks that's what
that was good question yeah yeah over
here yes I have two questions first
question is on the boat data pipeline
architecture that you showed in one you
were using Hawk primarily and in the
other one you will you are using green
DIA can I still not use green plum or
hawk and take the advantage of the
already existing Hadoop ecosystem
components like hive or Impala that I
have and still use matte lip along with
that so mad lip is actually available
for Impala so you can use you can use
that was impala for high if there's
currently no port and yeah for the time
being that's it for the Hadoop support
so you can use either Impala or hawk
that's right and the second question is
the example that you showed for traffic
incidents yeah it looked like a bit of
real-time analysis that is happening as
the incidents are happening you are
probably charting them along yeah and so
how near near real-time it is because
when you introduce something like
MapReduce jobs we are expecting high
latency of updates in data so how do you
take care of that so in fact this is the
whole feed is happening every five
minutes of the just the the draft
traffic of London feed is coming in
every five minutes so in fact it's not
like a super real-time feed and we just
have a batch job running I think every
10 minutes that updates the app so so
the data is fairly recent but it's not
like real-time streaming data although
we have a gem fire that can handle that
if we had streaming data what was the
name that you just mentioned Jim pie
gemfire this is this is our in-memory
database that is able to handle
streaming data is it open source as well
no no this of this particular product is
actually not open source oh thank you
thank you hello hi hey
is the training of models using Madlib
distributed over the nodes as well yeah
that is distributed over all the nodes
and we actually we our Madlib team has
actually put a lot of engineering effort
into that and a lot of thought because
of course as a lot of you may know it's
not it's not trivial to paralyze all of
these machine learning algorithms and
it's it's not not not not simple at all
so but all of the algorithms we met that
they make use of your full cluster and
all of your compute power and they try
to minimize data movement as much as
possible okay yeah I have a question of
mode since there have been some
questions about which one is open source
and which one is proprietary could you
maybe use one of your examples slide 23
or 25 and point out with your open
source completely solved act so there is
a community edition for all of our
products so if you just wanted to try
this out or whatever you can do it
indefinitely and and and just play
around with it and our Hadoop
distribution you can also just download
the image you can deploy it on a small
cluster and and that is fine greenplum
is it's not open source but you can also
download the community edition of that
matte lip is completely open source so
so we have a bunch of developers in Palo
Alto work on this full time and it's
completely free of charge and then
there's no licensing licensees involved
and you can as I mentioned you can use
that on postgres and also on some other
systems all the tools on here they're
they're free and for our data stack well
well gem fires is closed source but you
can also download the image of that does
that answer your question or yeah yeah
thank you all right thanks so that's
another question yeah hi I have a
question about the you said you did they
you did sentiment analysis on the tweet
yeah I said you did on
provide sentiment analysis I was just
interested in how you got the the like
positive negative sentiment words oh
okay yeah so there is a library called
NLP arc tweet it's bye-bye some American
University I forget and what they do is
they actually had a bunch of humans
label instances of tweets and instances
of words i think it was actually on
Mechanical Turk and they had for each
tweet that three people labeler to get
more accuracy because humans don't
always label it accurately either and
they used that for semi-supervised
learning to get a sentiment score and
it's an open source library and I can
also post a link to that later on and we
leverage that library to get a sentiment
score for those tweets okay thank you
any further questions okay so I think
it's a great idea of the photo to makes
so much of their work and so much of
their research effort open source and
open to the public for use so yeah so
that's a great thing and very much in
line with what Travis was speaking about
today so yeah this is the end of the
session and this is the end of the
regular conference stocks so let's thank
Robert
you
you